[music]
[clap]
How to develop game plan game how to have g
I wanted to ask you for yourself, and I shot it here.
I liked it so much that I could communicate directly with the kids in the development zone.
You really showed me that there's a game in motion.
It was fun.
[music]
By living.
Gentlemen, I really happened to have three moderately obvious ways to write my lungs
I'm doing it again.
I was just looking at the part that I think is really ours
He's gone up.
If you blame me for the thought of the former senator,
I shared it and thought more.
[music]
wire
5 na na na na na
[music]
[clap]
I am very pleased to be able to introduce our game.
Thank you very much to the people in Google who provided this place.
Thank you so much for being able to receive the opportunity to promote the game
I do not have much, but I am really grateful for the opportunity.
Togami that u received from them in the future, and then judges
Based on the things that you have told us, we will be ready to launch again next week.
Pray for them to know more about the Kibbie Adventure to those around the world.
I'll do it
[music]
Now, the Korean game ecosystem is in crisis because of lack of diversity and polarization.
The festival, which played the song, is a primer that can overcome this crisis.
I think it is the same event.
4 Wrap the side of the herb slowly and push the mouse to cleanse
We're talking swift swap 4 l 5 l in the future.
Red Byrd All indie games will laugh wide
We can do our best to make peaceful reunification.
We will make an effort to fight each other.